can we practice something
can we yeah together can you give me an
assignment and i'll and and then correct
me
can i are you going to write it or
you're going to say i'll just probably
say it
just maybe i don't know if i was in the
class
okay and you were testing me to say it i
mean it's about writing but okay
uh i've given you the four voices right
plus writing like you talk right
so you got writing like you talk you've
got
that that high voice that's a lot of
chit chat
stuff boy you won't believe what
happened and then man you know knock me
for a feather but i was there you know
then there's the fancy voice poetic
very lots of images metaphors similes
all that kind of crap
and then there's that red and song where
you take something and you repeat it
anything it doesn't matter whatever you
say you can repeat it three times
whatever you say you can say it twice
whatever you say
you can say it louder whatever you say
you can say it softer
whatever you can say you can say it with
more feeling whatever you say you can
say it deadly now as
any phrase is repeatable you just have
to repeat it
and then add the rest of the sentence
the rest of the sentence
is what would be different see in a
larger sense
we cannot what dedicate we cannot
what consecrate we cannot what
hallow this ground so that's the
repetition
and then uh the last voice is total
nonsense
now do you want to do it is that what
yeah would you want to give me a topic i
i couldn't
oh no we don't do topics you don't do
topics okay i'm sorry
i don't do whatever you don't know
i gotta call your manager here then so
you're just gonna in other words i'm
i'm gonna call out the voice you know
what i want you to do is just to talk
and if you talk eventually you'll
probably get into something you remember
or
something will come up don't worry about
it so if you fail who cares you know
what okay
right yeah okay however
i will say if i say straight talk
or if i say lost world that's fancy
schmancy
if i say red and sung that's the
repetitious voice
if i say absence of field meaning no
rhyme or reason
just nonsense and if i say like you talk
just talk like you talk okay so you'll
just start
uh blabbing about anything are you ready
i think so yeah okay ready go
okay noticing that food prices are going
up a lot it's
things seem very expensive and i'm not
quite sure why
but straight talk it's it's really
you're going into the market and i'm
noticing a dollar increase in what i
normally buy
now you're still talking like you talk
you got to get that high voice
i went in the market like god what am i
crazy did i get you know okay
got to go up there okay so keep going
straight talk so i'm at the market the
other day and there's this woman and
she's in my way and i'm trying to get to
the food
and the stuff is not on sale like i
thought it was supposed to be and then
i see that song
sorry that one is the repetition
repetition
the food that we eat
brings us life but if life
brings us nothing but bills
and duty and chores
and errands and they they don't take us
anywhere
lost world fancy schmancy
oh um
according to the gdp uh
let me know let me rephrase that um it's
hard to do it when you're talking
because we don't talk that way no no no
see it's almost as if i'm writing a a
letter or something um
it has come to my attention that food
prices
have escalated beyond the normal
day-to-day
more poetry come on okay fancy schmancy
it has come to my attention that food
which is life
which is what sustains us which is what
gives us
a reason to be with our loved ones and
and
break daily bread and and
love love one another and and come
together as community
good but you're not writing in that
style you're still
talking like you talk okay it would have
to be poetic
okay i thought it was but because no no
you were doing uh not good phrases okay
but you could talk that way
okay so but you got to write poetically
and what's the one that's abstract
because life because life streamed out
like a rhythm upon the cloistered hills
of
of existence breaks however many stars
that
fuel the clouds that break into the
heart and expose
the truth of your own soul rigid against
tribulation
striven against death broken open
against life
the platitudes of existence and the
small icicles that form
inside the caverns of your soul break
out of you you know that's
but that's lost world you've
got to be able to do that okay wow
okay and it's hard to do it when you're
talking see that's why this is about
writing it's not about talking
so it's harder for you to do that but
that's what you would have to shift into
and then keep going absence of field
and that is where i'm almost asked not
what your country can do for you
no you're making sense oh okay well okay
um so food
life love death
honor that's a field because you're
saying one word at a time
each one is different but that's a field
it it's a
it's a logical progression so each
unit can't be the same as the one before
or else you're establishing a field like
an electrical field a gravitational
field
this is no field so the words and the
phrases are like all jumbled up
but if you just do the same thing that's
a field
so you could do two of them but then the
third thing has got to be a phrase
then another phrase then something
doesn't you know you got to just keep
breaking sentence structure around you
have to practice these things they're
not as simple
no this is difficult you know very
difficult
custom shaved nether of any
kind of the sofa retains black teeth
of soft there in the eyeballs of
no one came it father
hair broken nostril
the shiny light of the sea that
protrudes over the waves
here nowhere stream
captain broken arrow it's always
in the gut of nothing was done
he was a champion see i'm just
that's absence of field nothing can ever
connect or converge you can't have a
field
writing a sentence is a field subject
verb object proposition you know it's
okay sentences of fields this would be
an
absence of field math
gold belly of the beast golden wheat
air something long now
because you've done a lot of short
things ask not what your country can do
for you
good but don't finish the sentence ask
not what your country can
and then stop see okay
but that's a technique that's been used
in writing
in the 20th century by a lot of writers
including
james joyce this stream of consciousness
and you might do that if you were having
a character
who was either having a hallucination or
they were
demented having dementia or
someone is falling and you're trying to
what it's like to be falling
what goes through a person's mind not in
normal sentences but everything is
colliding because it's all happening in
five seconds
as they're falling so you could use the
technique
to con someone's drowning you know you
would use absence of field for that
and so in in these four other tonalities
not the
the regular voice quote unquote
that sharpens the the tool that that
strengthens the muscle how does that
help do you pay attention
to how the writer is working or do you
just enjoy the story
depends depends on whether i'm playing
something or reading something
and there are other distractions going
on okay what about music
do you listen to any kind of classical
music at all yes i have
well have you ever listened to bruckner
and really paid attention to what
bruckner does
compared to let's say brahms bruckner is
absence of field
a lot bruckner's got tonalities
and changes that are very mysterious and
very sublime
whereas brahms has got these melodies
that
roll over almost like to be read and
sung
so if you pay attention to writers and
you pay attention to composers
and you pay attention to almost any kind
of art picasso
uh any painter you will see that they do
different things
all the time yeah they might have their
basic
i'll say writing in their own voice
approach
but they use all these other techniques
the next time you read a book
you know a good novel i promise you
you're going to see writing like you
in your own voice you're going to see
lost world which is poetic
you know fancy description or something
you're going to see red and sun once in
a while
look charles dickens opens up tale of
two cities with
was the best of times it was the worst
of times it was the
season of this was the winter of
discontent you're going to see
repetition
you're also going to see absence of
field sometime where
the work is very stream of consciousness
whether it's james joyce or virginia
woolf or tony morrison or
writers who do that you're going to see
it but
you can't be reading for pleasure you
have to be reading
like you're paying attention i know how
to drive a car
i would have no idea how to fix the
engine
but a mechanic he understands how the
engine works
and when people look at writing most
people
they don't look under the hood to see
what's going on
they just learn how to drive and turn
the wheel and start and stop and go fast
and go slow
but a a writer if you study writing that
question you asked
asked me karen you will go oh look he
just went from writing like you talk
to fancy schmancy oh look he just went
from fancy schmancy
to straight talk
holden caulfield catcher in the rye does
it all the time
so you will see those four tones and
the tone of writing in your own voice
you will see that
being done just the way beethoven
you will see these changes of tone
of tonality of dynamic that's why i call
it
tonal dynamics because it's dynamic it
changes
so you're going to see it in literature
all over the place
so was the first part of becoming a
better writer to pay attention
not just to your own writing to other
works of art
not even not even literature but music
there's no great writer that hasn't paid
attention
to almost every writer that came before
them going all the way back to
gilgamesh the iliad the odyssey
augustine's confessions uh catullus's
poems
in the first century bc uh you know
dante they they know it all and they
don't just read
for pleasure they read like a writer
they read like an artist
they pay attention they study oh look
what he's doing look what he's doing and
then they
copy it a little bit and then they
extend it
even further you know artists are always
influenced by the artists who came
before them and then they
go one better so
yeah whatever you do whether you're a
sculptor or a painter or a writer or a
composer
yeah you've got to study the people who
came before you and see what they're
doing
because it's a conversation artists are
talking to each other across
the millennia they're talking and
you want to see what the conversation is
you want to know what dante said to
shakespeare
and what shakespeare said to homer and
what homer said to
uh philip roth
or ann sexton you know what are they
saying
not in the met in the message but in the
technique
in the technique oh oh look what braum
look what the bruckner did look at the
way he extended that chord
and did a variation that was interesting
that was different from anything
beethoven did
oh look what mahler did look how he did
that you study it
any composer you ask them man they've
studied them all
so being conscious and you want to see
absence of field
check out elliot carter oldest
he might be dead by now but he was in
his hundreds 100 the last time i heard
he wrote a string quartet just recently
listen to beethoven's
last six string quartets
a lot of that is absence of field as a
matter of fact
if you listen to beethoven's um piano
sonata
110 or 111 i can't remember which one it
is
i was listening to it one day and
there's like a four
bar section in there that if you hear it
you if you're listening you'll hear it
it's
jazz where he got it i don't know
i mean boom but if you listen but
all of a sudden it's jazz and then it
goes back
to the normal kind of progressions that
they
did in in beethoven's time so
his string quartets his late piano
concertos you're going to hear a lot of
stuff and you're going to go
well where'd that come from how did he
do that
because as an artist you always want to
see not what did they do but
how did they do it how did they
create that it's not about the plot or
the story
it's about the technique how did they do
that how did they do that
you